my name is Emily Reagan I'm a
participant in the Washington Hillsdale
internship program currently interning
at the Heritage Foundation and it's my
privilege to introduce our final speaker
of the day dr. Larry Arne is the 12th
president of Hillsdale College he
received his BA from Arkansas State
University and his MA and PhD in
government from the Claremont Graduate
School formerly the director of research
for Sir Martin Gilbert the official
biographer of Winston Churchill at
Worcester College Oxford University dr.
Arne was from 1985 to 2000 president of
the Claremont Institute he is author of
Liberty and learning of the evolution of
American education and the founders
Keith the divine and natural connection
between the declaration in the
Constitution and what we risk by losing
it please join me in welcoming dr. Larry
yarn
thank you dear very much thank you David
Bob Thank You senator Lee you know he
comes he comes up here once a month and
brings his staff and we sit and read old
documents and so I know that for once a
month for a couple of hours there's at
least one senator who's not doing
something unconstitutional although
things like that are regulated by the
government it could be illegal I don't
really know and thank you professor
Porteous and post read oh the two peas
because they shown today and it was
lovely to watch them and then all of you
here today thank you for being here and
all of you watching online I want to
apologize to you
we gave everybody in the audience a
sandwich for lunch it was good I think
my mind was and I want all to be
watching to know that if you will just
sign up and give us your email we will
email you a photograph of a sandwich
we do we do a lot of online teaching at
Hillsdale College and it's we enjoyed a
lot and its really great but of course
the main thing we do is with kids like
these ones who've been doing these
introductions up here and we sit in a
room with somebody old like me
or semi old like RJ and Kevin and 20
young people and I want you to know
that's just a magical experience and
about the best way anybody can spend his
time and you can't do that online
because you can't do it for large
numbers of people at a time but you're
invited to come watch it if you want to
on the campus a lot of people do come to
the campus and you'll see that that's
what happens there my subject is
returning to constitutional government
and I'm in favor of that and I I had an
a journalist the other day an
intelligent man asked me well then
you've taken sides
he said you even talked like it's a
moral thing and I said well justice is a
moral virtue it is but I said remember
you have to take sides and he said why
and I said well the view that any form
of government is ok as long as it fits
the age that's the doctrine that RJ post
Reno just described that's a that's
aside the view that there's no objective
way to know what kind of government is
right that's aside the view that the
Constitution is a good thing that's
aside and we at the college were founded
in 1844 that's a long time ago 170 years
nearly to be on that side and a lot of
people from our College have died in
wars and done great service for the
country a lot more remembered in this
building where we are here in Washington
in the name of those principles and that
doesn't change the fact however that it
is an academic institution and I'm going
to say something at the end about the
importance of
that fact why it's a very important fact
but I'll say at the beginning that of
course we have to proceed by making
arguments and proving things and so you
just heard these two talks and thank you
for listening to them and they're a
little involved aren't they you know
these guys are very hard teachers both
of them and I myself am a pretty hard
teacher and over the years we pick up a
lot you have to go into things deeply
and so I urge everybody watching and all
of you here we're making a lot of tools
available so you can read for yourself
the original materials about these
debates and that means the ones from the
beginning of the country but that also
look there's my friend Susanna how are
you dear I haven't seen you in a long
time
excuse me it's one of my students and
not just the founders but these
progressives including the contemporary
ones I mean there's a guy you should
read by the way I'm hoping to get him
here for a debate one of these days
right now he calls himself the Brit well
and he permits himself to be called and
I think it's a fault and him I criticize
him for it he permits himself to be
called the regulatory czar his name is
Cass Sunstein and he is advocated in so
much writing he said he is advocated in
so much writing in these words that if
the government allocates the right to
speak then speech will be freer because
more equally distributed and he's
written a book about that just lately
and it's a very vigorous defense of all
that and I think that one should go and
read him I mention him as a source to
which you should attend that's important
now it's a good time to think about the
subject of returning the constitutional
rule and it's all to that as an
alternative to the bureaucratic state
for two reasons
they both amount to the claim that time
may be running out in other words we
should probably think about him now or
else we're not going to get to but there
are two reasons why one might think that
and I myself don't think that we're at
the final stages
this great controversy but things are
serious now and they're too obvious
signs that they're serious what I'm is
we're broke
well actually is my friend mark Stein
likes to say if we had 14 trillion more
dollars then we'd be broke but he's he's
actually wrong about that it come to
find out well he and he knows he as I
imagined because really what's happened
is the government is about 15 trillion
dollars in debt now and that's a lot and
that's about as big as the gross
domestic product and that never happened
before in American history except during
the Second World War and that happened
because of course that was the greatest
military conflict in all of human
history and this has happened in time of
relative peace and so it's an ordinary
operating phenomenon and so the country
is richer than it's ever been
in fact richer than any human society
has ever been and yet it's government is
15 trillion in debt and it doesn't mean
the country's broke it just means that
there's going to have to be a very major
transfer of resources from the private
to the public sector if it continues and
it is continuing at a very rapid pace
and likely to accelerate and so this
question which is my main theme today of
a transfer from the private to the
public sector if you just think about
that for a minute there's never been a
government in history in which that's a
more sensitive thing to happen than ours
because ours is founded but the founders
take great pride in saying on a unique
relationship between the public and the
private sector and that relationship is
simple it is that they are different and
that the private sector controls the
public sector and so there's an
adjustment underway and obviously if you
study the founding of the country that's
a fundamental thing right you may think
it's a great adjustment to
and many many people do think that but
remark the fact that whether it's a good
adjustment or an ill adjustment it's a
fundamental adjustment it changes
everything now a second thing has not
been mentioned yet and it seems to be
terribly important worth mentioning and
that is if it's true and it is true that
now about fifteen trillion is the gross
domestic product and about six point
eight trillion is local state and
federal spending and half of fifteen
trillion as you know is seven and a half
trillion when you're talking about
trillions it's good math of Mark Boise
works the way it does because nobody can
understand what one trillion isn't it
you can know the relationship between
fifteen and seven what if it gets over
half and you know if you just look at
the new program the health care program
and you look at the growth in existing
programs you've got to think of
everything stays as it is that the
government is soon enough going to be
larger than the private sector and
that's showing up in another incredibly
sensitive thing in our constitutional
system and that is the representative
functioning of the system and this is
just a you know it just it just is to
say it's a neutral thing you don't have
to believe one thing or another about
this just to understand the phenomenon
and the phenomenon is Madison writes
this in the 63rd Federalist and prettier
language then I will quote this morning
but it's very worth reading the 63rd
Federalist he says that for the first
time it's a purely representative form
and that means that the sovereignty the
legitimate authority to rule is located
outside the government and there's
nobody in the government that possesses
that but that means that the only way we
collectively sovereigns have to control
the government is at election time we
don't get to do anything except at
election time and so elections are the
critical point in American politics
and it's just a fact that if you take
the 10 largest givers in politics today
about four and a half of them our places
from which their money is derived from
the public sector they are public
employee unions and they give
overwhelmingly to one party and not to
the other party and they advocate things
that make the government larger and that
means that the government is a massive
fact in the electoral system by which
the government is chosen you heard Kevin
Porteous read that funny thing from the
Law Review article I think's where some
really brilliant man wrote it and it's
just lovely about how you know the the
Commission decides to investigate and
the Commission reports to itself and the
Commission enforces and the Commission
kills you and then it buries you and and
then it takes your estate and then it
prosecutes your heirs and you know I
think that was the list of what the
Commission does the Commission is very
involved in the electoral system now so
what about that is that right I think it
depends it depends on whether you think
this certain argument which RJ post reto
made with great clarity he's good at
that is so because you might think that
the founders were right about something
what they thought was you know cuz
they're there they are on our painting
over there I've just pointed over there
to the painting that's if you know
anything about the Kirby Center you know
there's this really great painting of
the signing of the Constitution and
there's Washington and Madison in the
middle and Hamilton nearby and Ben
Franklin sitting down because he was
really old and creaky and what those
guys thought was they thought that men
are not angels and angels do not govern
men and so whatever it is about us that
makes us need law also makes us makes it
necessary that those who enforce the law
operate under limit
and they proved their loyalty to that by
the kind of institutions they set up
because those institutions remember them
remember what they knew all those guys
who are right in the Constitution United
States they knew that these checks and
balances and restraint we're going to
apply to them personally they set it up
over themselves and so it was never
their argument that a class a person
like us learned people who lead a
revolution and risk their fortunes their
lives and their sacred honor you know
they could have said you know guys like
that you can always trust them and so
you always got to have guys like that
and as long as you got guys like that
you can let them do whatever they want
to in the government they might have
said that but they didn't say that they
said that even guys like that are not
angels and then this alternative
argument is that we've reached a stage
in history in which there's a kind of
person now and they can be trusted to
run the government with some checks and
some recurrence to the people admittedly
but in general you don't need separation
of powers and you don't need all that
stuff because we're going to be
scientific and impartial and nonpartisan
and professional in our standards and
and and those things amount to that
great state of a public administration
we refer to as hunky-dory it's all great
well I'm not in the hunky-dory school
and and so I'll make an argument about
three kinds of things you might do two
of them have been mentioned when I'm not
one is we should protect and respect the
popular branches of the government
distasteful though that may seem also we
should make them more accountable now I
stand with every American I think
they're actually 7% of the Americans who
will not answer the question yes the
question being do you hold the Congress
the United States in complete and utter
contempt everybody does I do except you
can't really limit its authority over
the government without limiting our home
because it does just so happen they're
the ones that we elect and they've
maneuvered they're complicit the
institution or many many of its members
are complicit in this system by which
they escape responsibility for the bad
things and they get to make their living
as Ombudsman doing favors for us with
the bureaucracy just the other day
somebody came up to me who lives near
Hillsdale and said about a great favor
our congressman I won't miss his name he
he's friend of mine I'm for him had done
for this lady because somebody there was
some visa paper that somebody that
somebody was adopting a kid and they
couldn't get the kid into the country
and so the congressman intervened it's a
nice story it's good that he did that
and of course they love him for that and
good that he did that he is a very good
guy but of course that really isn't
quite what his job is
is it his job is to take positions on
the great issues of the day like the
ones we're talking about today and they
used to stand or fall by that and there
wasn't so much that went on in this town
that you could affect so you need to
respect the representative branches but
also I would do a couple of things one
of them is I would there's a few states
that have this
and I wish they all did I think that you
should have impartial rules in drawing
congressional districts so that a very
high percentage of the districts are
competitive election should be a really
whacking big argument and we're having
one right now it's very good for the
country it's good that it's so ugly and
hotly contested in my opinion we're not
ready to go to the deepest questions
that are before us right now because the
people who are running for office now
have not really lived and made their
careers at a time like this one whereas
there's some younger ones that look
better to me but still they're doing
better than they used to do and we're
examining the questions will all
elections should be very competitive and
I would change that if I if I could I
would get rid of gerrymandering and then
I would some of these reforms senator
Lee talked about a bill he's God that
would make the Congress responsible for
the expensive regulations they would son
said unless the Congress passed these
regulations and I like that bill for a
lot of reasons and what I'm is it'll put
the heat on senator Lee more and you
know I'm not criticizing him I like him
very much but but that's that would be
the effect for him of the passing of the
bill because shouldn't they really be
responsible both for the cost of the
regulations and for the cost when there
is a cost of not regulating because
there can be such a cost of course there
can be terrible things happen there can
be people died there can be failures of
safety and wouldn't it be great if
Congress was responsible for that
because the thing about Congress is you
get rid of them and get another one and
especially if the if the seats are very
competitive and then what you'd want is
you'd want elections that used to be
like you know because congressmen didn't
used to come and talk to you about the
details of how your kid goes to school
because the truth is they don't know any
more about that than anybody does in
fact know quite a bit less about that
then I would happen to know
because what do I do for a living but
but they it's not their lookout right
they have constitutional purposes they
should stand or fall by how they serve
them
that's a reform we should do everything
to get that a second one I've only got
three
there should be an effort to simplify
the government I can tell you in the
management of a college you know in a
college you know accepting myself
everybody's really smart and you know
it's just it's you know it's a place
where smart people gather and you know
in the administration and on the faculty
and in the student body you know
everybody there's a lot of brainpower
and on the other hand the only reason we
can run it when we can run it in most
days we can it's because we keep it
simple as we can like we don't believe
in ever having very many rules
and if we have a meeting to decide to do
something I'm you know everybody laughs
when I say it now cuz I say it I've said
it so much now that it's everybody's
habit we always try not to remember more
than three things by the way don't I
have a list of three right now that way
if my paper burns up I'll still know
what they are but that's a good idea
right in other words RJ was giving his
talk from his iPad but he had a paper
with him and he said I always try to be
extra cautious I don't really need you
either the iPad or the paper but I got
them both well me too I got my iPad here
and I got my paper but I'll tell you
what a profound principle of
constitutionalism this is because you
think it's funny but it's actually one
of the most important reflections of
human nature that James Madison ever
wrote he writes it will be of little
avail to the people that laws are made
by their own choice if the laws be so
voluminous that they cannot be read or
so in coherent that they cannot be
understood if they be repealed to revise
before they are promulgated or undergo
such incessant change that no man who
knows what the law is today can guess
what it will be tomorrow
now do you know why that's important
there's no better way on earth to learn
the importance than that than to teach
classes because what you learn in there
is that success is a product of every
mind in the room and it doesn't matter
how smart you are or how much you know
the question is what do you do together
to produce learning and that is an exact
synonym for constitutional rule in all
its forms if the laws are clear we can
all help to enforce them and we can all
live on them each one of us can carry
the law in his own breasts and I'll give
you my favorite examples because they're
beautiful the Northwest Ordinance is
just under 3,000 words long and all that
is achieved was to provide for the first
time in all of human history the
complete set of rules for a free
government to grow across a continent
that had not even been explored at the
time that the law was written and I'm
saying it's less than 3,000 words and
it's handsome reading you can read it in
30 minutes and the Homestead Act which
was signed by Abraham Lincoln in the
middle of the Civil War gave away 10% of
the land area of the United States of
America to over 2 men almost 2 million
families and it is 1420 words long and
that means it's a law that everybody can
read and if everybody can read you know
I was involved I'm you know I'll
disgrace myself yet further before God
and man by admitting that I helped to
bring the California Civil Rights
initiative into being and we had this
magnificent tool of victory
it was just overwhelmingly powerful and
nothing could resist it we in the
biggest state in the Union we had about
six or seven hundred thousand dollars as
I remember and somebody there was a
securities initiative on the ballot and
I think that
they spent like 45 million dollars for
and against it and in three weeks before
the vote more people knew about our
initiative than knew about that one and
of course it means cuz we have any money
it was identified four people
overwhelming by a hostile press and yet
had a huge majorities for it right
through election day when it won you
know what the key was it's very pretty
and very simple and it uses the language
of the Declaration of Independence and
it just establishes the government of
the United States or the government of
California in this case in its various
operations is not to on any occasion
discriminate or prefer on the ground of
the color of one skin or gender and
everybody can understand that it's
simple and beautiful and then everybody
can get behind it and so we should start
a rule that we're only gonna pass laws
like that and you know I can tell you
there is in this town some people
working on that now and I'm proud to say
that they some of them have written that
they got the idea of it by sitting in a
seminar right here in this building
because one day I said you know they
said what should we actually do you know
and that's a great question to ask
anybody who's a teacher you know cuz I
don't know what to do
I am giving you these three points
though and I said you know I held up by
the way because I happen to have brought
it print it out the Higher Education Act
of 2007 I think it would know well it
was started in 2007 but then it was
completed later under the next
administration and that bill you know
it's the sister seventh reauthorization
of one of the ugliest pieces of
legislation in all of human history the
first Higher Education Act of 1965 and
I'm telling you it's pug ugly you should
just go read it and the new one is worse
and it was written when the Republicans
had a majority in the Congress and I
held it up and I said you know don't do
that anymore and they said you know cuz
by the way it's a miracle you could even
do that I don't know a few particular
people in the room did that with people
like you did it you know a bunch of
people who are 28 and 31 years old we've
got law school education most of
and you write this intensely and
immensely complex thing telling people
how to run a college when you by the way
you know you have no knowledge of that
whatsoever and I happen to know
something about that whereas 12 years
ago I didn't know anything about it and
I learned cuz I would have died if I
hadn't you see so the point is I said
don't write that and they said well what
should we write and I held up the
Homestead Act I said it's been proved
you can write this 800 page monstrosity
could you write this 1400 word beauty
and and you could see they were taken by
the charm of it the IRA law individual
retirement account law under Reagan it's
pretty simple the Chilean health care
and retirement system is pretty simple
and they're not simple enough nor
beautiful enough but they're a start
what if you just passed some laws that
were simple and lovely and invited
everybody to cooperate with them now you
wouldn't need this rulemaking process
producing these endless complications so
I favor that and I think by the way
these first two things these are both
things that could be done pretty soon
there's to say they could be in
somebody's political platform right now
and it doesn't mean that you have to
disturb the entitlement state that's
going to take something sort of
complicated like maybe it's a Paul Ryan
plan or something like that I don't know
what but something like that because
there's huge flows of money involved
these are points just about ways of
governance and their effect if you could
implement them would be to restore
additional authority in the hands of
people and make them accountable at the
same time you say because authority and
responsibilities are supposed to go
together like I have authority at
Hillsdale College and you know something
messes up their who do they call whose
fault is it you know usually the cycle
goes like this something goes wrong and
then I find out about it and somebody's
criticizing me or wondering what went
wrong and the first thing not to do is
find out what it is I'm accountable and
that goes with the authority and it'd be
wrong if I had one or the other without
the other
just one or the other you see the last
thing is we should implement separation
of powers and the regulatory agencies I
mentioned that came up several times
this morning and I mentioned a couple of
experiences I've had with that I used to
live in California and there was the
South Coast Air Quality Management
District still a great power there I
imagine I'll hear from before the week
is out because I mentioned their name
but they had at the time 1200 employees
and they had about a hundred of them
doing public relations as I recall and
the way very good at it but it's what
they did and they and here's how they
worked here's how they functioned I came
to quarrel with him a little bit here
and there and and you know they did what
they do they offered me a contract and I
said well you know I don't really do
that and they said but we'd like to have
your help and I said well you shall and
they didn't take that as good news but
the way they were formed was they had
power to regulate anything that gave a
certain kind of admission there's a long
ring list of them into the atmosphere
any process any anything that did that
and they made the rules and they
enforced the rules and they adjudicated
the rules they got their budget entirely
from fees and fines placed on what they
were pleased to call the regulated
community community interesting
expression and so they're very powerful
people and they would like tell you if
you want to paint some surface they tell
you what machine you could use stuff
like that right and of course they have
enormous discretion and they built
themselves a palace if you go to where
the what is it 57 and the 22 freeways
come together now the 60 and the 57
freeways come together in Southern
California up on the hill is it
gorgeous white palace of a thing and I
remember I began to turn people's heads
and I first heard the suggestion from a
mayor of a town good idea I thought she
said you know there were all three
branches of government and one is that
right and there were some reforms in
other words the only reform that really
happened was they had to put their
budget into the state general fund and
then they got an appropriation back out
so they didn't have the same an
incentive to find people or put fees on
them but shouldn't you fix all of that
especially at the judicial part because
regulatory agencies are in the executive
branch and so they must not have
especially judicial functions because
the judicial function is the place where
the arm of the law comes and grabs you
the citizen and says something's going
to happen to you but also they shouldn't
really have the legislative function
either and I can tell you people gave a
couple of examples of how that worked
but I'll give you one close to home
in 1974 Hillsdale College you know which
was founded in 1844 and remember has
never had a nickel from the government
and remember has done fantastic service
for the government read the story of the
Civil War and if you read it truly you
will find out that we were very much
involved in that and there were people
on our campus who knew Abraham Lincoln
and everybody loved his cause and helped
to invent the platform on which he ran
for president it's just true lovely too
and you know that makes us a little bit
older than the United States Department
of Education
in 1974 we got a letter from Joseph
Califano and it's in the campus video
I'd love to talk about this and it said
that because students were bringing
federal aid which was aid directly to
the students to the college that we had
to sign the compliance documents and
that's the money now that we're famous
for not taking we did take it for a
while
that's to say if a student showed up
with the GI Bill or stood up with any of
the federal programs today we went
through a big debate on the campus and
we decided we'd never asked for got
money from the government or accept any
directly to us but it was these were
student programs and it was up to the
students whether they wanted to do it or
not that was our position hammered out
through the 1960s well in 74 they said
well you got this money now you're gonna
have to comply and comply means you know
and Hillsdale College I count them up
every other year so I think in Hillsdale
College we have about 95 pages of rules
if you put the student faculty and staff
handbooks together
well the aid the part that concerns the
student aid is several hundred pages you
know probably about 500 now it was 475
last time I counted but you know that
was yesterday and also you can't read
those rules I was told by my lawyer
you'll never be able to read them well
we told a guy to go jump in the lake we
don't want you we don't want it we're
not gonna do it no and so they commenced
an enforcement action against us and we
had to go before one of these
administrative judges and Hillsdale
College as you know is located in South
Central Michigan and the Health
Education and Welfare Department it was
at the time is located in Washington DC
so they scheduled a hearing in Denver
Colorado
and you know for efficiency sake and so
we went out to Denver and we get
ourselves up and got our boots on and
took our lawyers and pled before this
administrative judge and darn if we
didn't up and win we won months and
months vast expense so then the
Commission you know the equivalent the
hell that you overruled
so we won in front of their judge and
then they took it away and so then we
went into the courts and we eventually
ended up we were in one jurisdiction in
Grove City College and Pennsylvania was
another we won a better victory than
they won ours wasn't great but theirs
was terrible you know pity both of us
and so it got appeal to the Supreme
Court of the United States and there if
we had only had five more votes we would
have won and of course that's been
pretty good for us you know since but
who knows you know because I'm reading
today Obama's gonna make tuition free
and tell every college how it's got to
spend its money that by the way is the
cost what you pay for your independence
maybe you get security except you don't
you pay your freedom they're very
interested in how you teach now the
standard you've got to meet is called
diversity whereas the name of the thing
that they're regulating is University
and those are cognate words and they
mean incompatible things University
means many things turning both of main
many things turning University means
they turn into one thing diversity means
they turn into more than one thing and
so there is a person in a official of a
high official in MIT in great college
who loves to say that the purpose of the
University of Michigan is diversity
and that's a contradiction in terms and
yet the attempt to enforce that
oncologist is far advanced and coming
upon us and we're gonna resist it
because we think that the purpose of
college is written in its name it means
partnership and that makes it compatible
with the word University which means a
bunch of people coming together through
argument and debate to do something
precious and high I don't think the
government should be able to put any
body through the process that we were
put through in 1974 I think it is a
violation of the rights of man as they
are written in the laws of nature and of
nature's God I argue that and I think
that I think if you made those three
reforms you would have done a lot and I
think that there's a basis for those
three reforms in fact I think there'll
be a basis for those three reforms
regardless what happens to the size of
the government and the expense of the
government in other words I think if
you've got a good argument and you can
make it that's a powerful position to be
in and it's very hard to get rid of that
position Alexander Solzhenitsyn used to
say if I could have one invention that
would make it possible to overcome this
government you know which he was living
under a government that put him in the
gulag and then had killed a hundred
million people and our government by the
way is not like that government it is
not violent and harsh in that way but it
is just a simple fact that it shares
some principles some intellectual roots
with that government and it's a radical
thing to say that but that word radical
means rude and I'm saying it's just so
it is so it can be proved it's proved in
our Constitution reader and then the
rest of our core curriculum and you can
think it's a good thing I'm just saying
they're related so the nation said that
the that the invention that you would
need
would be a little copier that could
reproduce paper that you could hide
about your person because then arguments
and ideas would go everywhere
isn't that a hopeful and optimistic
thing for him to write and that's in the
depths of the reign of the gulag and
what has happened since except that it's
been proved that he was correct so I do
those three things and I'll be ensuring
the answer to a question that dr.
Porteous was who's prematurely wise I
discovered by listening to him this
morning we're colleagues and I knew he
was good but he did a particularly good
job today I think and I expect a lot of
out of post rito cuz he's a Dean and he
did good today Kevin was asked how do
you bring this new form of bureaucratic
government under control and he said he
didn't know and I'll repeat I'll join
him in that I don't know either nobody
knows except I do know what to do now I
think and I also think I know what the
last step will look like and so I'll
describe them to you about now what to
do now is this this is why a college can
be of any use right now because colleges
are places that argue things and learn
things and publish things and submit
things to criticism and debate and ours
is doing that right now and by the way
it is true that our college has a
position on these questions and most
colleges claim they don't what they do
and you know we prepared to argue and
also never proceed without without
reference to their position and I repeat
my invitation to mr. Sunstein to come
here and debate probably busy right now
curbing the speech rights of the
American people so the first thing to do
is to argue the American Revolution had
a gestation period in one sense it was
about 2,000 years long because that's
the length of time over which the books
that the founders knew had been written
in another sense it was about a hundred
and fifty years long that's the length
of time that there were Europeans in the
new world and in another sense it lasted
from about 1763 until about 1776 when
the real conflict started in 1763 until
the Declaration of Independence was
produced in 1776 but you'd have to go a
little farther because the Constitution
the United States 11 years farther on
it's better although the same thing in
kind as it is better than the
constitutions that were written in 1776
so it took them a while of arguing and
thinking and talking and they got better
at it because that's what free people do
when they get together to learn and to
consider things by reason that's the
thing to do now and I'm telling you I
think it even in a very highly regulated
society that's going to prove to be a
very difficult thing to stop because
people do have a way of talking don't
they I'm in charge of 1,400 people
between the ages of 18 and 21 and I've
tried all kinds of things and finally
abandoned the effort to shut them up
the agitation for progressivism the
first ideas they came from the academic
world think of that
if we're gonna retrace our steps where
should we start the last step is harder
to imagine except we have the great
crises in human history to give us some
guidance
I've studied Winston Churchill a lot
also Abraham Lincoln also George
Washington
what were their lives like they saw some
terrible thing coming it's been a long
time figuring it out
they had gifts I mean it's just
incredible somebody asked me about
somebody running for president right now
is he in fact like Churchill I said sure
in some ways and you know I won't say
the waste but there are some ways yeah
in some good ways and they said well he
is greatest Churchill and I said well I
don't know why do you say how would you
tell and I'd say well they both
published books you could read them they
both were give speeches you could read
them Churchill was very great he said
once that he was describing why his
ancestor fighting ludes of 14th one all
the battles that he fought in the war
whereas the generals and the war went on
for 20 years I think and he was the
commander for eight and the generals on
the side of it when other side of him
who never did win and so every time he
went out in the field with the same
forces against the same enemy and every
time he did it he beat them what can
account for that Churchill says he says
any intelligent scribe can write down
what should have been done after the
fact but the great generals it seems
move their armies about as easily as
some people ride their horses from place
to place nothing but genius the diamond
and man can answer the riddles of war
and because genius is much rarer than
rarest and purest of diamonds wars are
mainly tales of metal
I think the efficient cause of
Michelangelo's David and Michelangelo's
pietà and Michelangelo's Moses is
Michelangelo and it mattered a lot that
he did it
and I think the efficient cause of the
United States is the min stay in that
portrait right there and it matters a
lot that they were the ones they were
not the only thing there were three
other kinds of causes but that cause you
need to get right so we've been reduced
to that miserable place where we need
great statesmanship to get out of this
mess but God has given it to us before
and also we do know the material with
which such a statement statesmen should
work because of the material cost of the
United States of America it's the land
and its people its formal causes its
constitution its final cause the beauty
that moved people to make our country is
expressed in the Declaration of
Independence well the land and the
people they're awful good in this
country and also they are surely aware
that if the original kind of government
that we were bequeathed by our fathers
is correct this new kind cannot be
correct and if this new kind is correct
and the original kind cannot be correct
and so people who claim as I claim that
this form of government won't work you
know what's wrong with it
what's wrong with it there too you can
put it in two ways it claims that the
founders are wrong that there is no
abiding or objective standard of good to
guide action as the current president of
the United States has written the very
idea of constitutional freedom means
that there cannot be any self-evident or
absolute truth he wrote that in the
audacity of hope' well the point is that
step one but step two is I would like to
have a lot of power please I don't know
that it's right to trust that argument
but then the second thing is another
more obvious thing yet is that we are
all human and that means that we should
all participate in the government over
us and constitutional government by the
way is very strong it is stronger than
bureaucratic government because so many
millions of people can help to make it
work whereas the other kind the kind we
have now means that really experts are
telling people what to do and I will
tell you I find in my won't work as a
teacher especially about managing a
college that's not a good way to go
people don't like it and you don't get
much done once the lady from an
accrediting agency she says dr. Arnn how
did you do such a good job controlling
these cost here you can I'll send you
our accreditation report if you wanted
to chose it's it's a world beater and I
said to the lady I said I didn't she
said who did I said everybody she said
wow how did she get them to do it I said
I asked
and they do it's great hope I think have
faith in the right as God gives us to
see the right thank you
and thank you very much and two people
at home I'll say that these people were
all paid $20 to stand up and so do you
we're gonna email you a photograph of a
$20 bill yes sir
this is a question from one of the
online viewers Josephine from Portland
Oregon who asks you mentioned that
elections are the best solution to the
to this problem how important is the
2012 election and stopping the
administrative state well it's very
important is it all important is it
fundamentally important I never liked
the tipping point argument because I
always say you know people friends of
mine I'll say okay what are you into
after we pass it so yeah I think it's
very important because I think there's a
lot of things going on right now that
remove discretion over the government
from the American people and and so I
think those things need to be contested
I I don't think that the election is
likely to be decisive simply positive or
negative for the simple reason that
first of all I'm not sure that we're
ready to fix this yet I'm not sure we as
a people have thought through what needs
thinking through to get to a place where
we could do what needs doing I think
instinct is with us and I think we're
learning all the time and getting better
and I think that's gonna have to go on
for a while and about the thing that
it's the end for good and all I don't
know about that I don't I don't think
that's true and there's a lot of reasons
why although you know must be because we
don't seem like a people beaten to us
and also the people in command right now
in much of the government I don't think
that the majority of them are simply
despotic and intent at all I think they
think that they seem a little angry
me now whereas the tone of progressivism
is r.j. for example described it a
little bit this morning and this he's
written about it it's often been smug
and superior you know we we know better
oh those naive founders thinking there
were universal truths you know that kind
of tone well they're a little ticked off
right now I think the president seems
angry to me and I think that's by the
way partly a sense that it's not going
is it ought to go and we got to have
more now to really make it go right
because this has been insufficient so I
fear that a little bit but that doesn't
amount to the same thing as as you know
real despotic intent where if I got to
kill somebody I'll kill them and it
doesn't matter how many that's not
what's happening here I don't think
and it could down the road somewhere but
that would require events to change
things in ways that I hope and believe
will not happen
hi I understand and I agree and admire
Hill sales position on government
funding my question is do tuition tax
credits is that a way to get around that
because it's not a direct funding going
to the student or Hill sales but it's
kind of backing tax credit and then also
what do you feel about vouchers and the
secondary and primary education system
do they have the same problems that
he'll snow would run into well that's a
very good question and the answer to
it's a little complex but I'll try to
simplify let me think for a minute and
did the Northwest Ordinance that I
mentioned earlier is the first federal
support to public schools you know in
article three says religion morality and
knowledge being necessary to good
government of them in the happiness of
mankind schools and the means of
education shall ever be encouraged then
what they do is in my opinion a model of
the way administrative things should
work
America when their domestic in their
nature and and something is local is
education because you know education is
radically local right now this is an act
of education but it's not a national
thing it's everybody attending to this
right now is going to benefit from it
and nobody else is and eat the work has
to be done by each person involved right
you know if I did okay good but it
depends on you to absorb it and ask me
questions so I get better anyway so the
point is here's what they did they set
aside land in each Township as an
endowment to States ever after to
support education in that Township I can
show you a section of land in each
Township I can show you where the
section is in Hillsdale Michigan it's
about a half a mile from the campus and
if you go back and look at the D it's a
sixteenth section in each Township if
you go back to the deed of that thing
you'll go all the way back to the
founding of the country and you'll find
that its history starts as something
that belonged to the federal government
is of course most of the federal land
did at one point or another so I'm not
against the government being involved in
education I'm against bureaucratic
government and that's what our college
is very keen not to fall prey to now
about schools what should happen is they
are a proper constitutional function of
states the state should provide for them
and it should do it in non-bureaucratic
ways and the reason any of this stuff
can go wrong is because you know
vouchers can go wrong and charter
schools can go wrong we're involved in
starting some charter schools and the
way we're doing it is they get the money
we don't we'll never have a nickel from
them directly or indirectly any money
that passes will pass from them to us
and our contract is if you will agree to
do what we suggest we will agree to make
the suggestion and we're helping people
start our charter schools and there's
gonna be a lot of them pretty soon
well if if they're let alone to manage
their affairs according to the rules of
good sense then they'll likely prosper
and the government used to be really
good at doing that whereas if the
government is bureaucratically organized
then it doesn't really matter what
device you use because what it did with
higher ed is it uses it as a way to run
colleges and so it depends right in
other words and see there's a gloomy
fact hidden in the answer I just gave
you if the country were to go entirely
down this road that it's going down then
it would be very difficult for our
college to continue to operate
eventually impossible you know we fight
to the end but you know why because it's
just you know step by step you just make
things harder every year and we've you
know we've in the recent years our
college has done very well and that's
because people want it to all over the
country all volunteers and you know one
prays that will continue and our job is
only to do the best we can but you can't
guarantee that depends on big events win
those charter schools and vouchers and
all that stuff will work lose those
nothing will work yes sir thank you for
your speech dr. Arnn and for everything
we've gotten here today let me suggest a
number for to your list not to make it
too complicated house rule 20 says that
all votes by the House of
Representatives have to occur on the
floor of the House of Representative I
don't understand why that's necessary
anymore I don't understand why we can't
have Congress act officially without
being here and as a native of Washington
I have some familiarity with the
influence that's not fair sir you're
trying to get them out of town
I am and it's actually totally against
my interest I own buildings here I mean
it probably has some of these people but
honestly I I would love to see them try
and pass a tax increase while shuffling
off into the strip mall next to a shoe
store I think that's a far better way of
getting representative government
without having them here it's a tough
gig here actually I mean they really
these guys maintain two households they
fly back and forth across the country
eventually you lose touch it's it's not
possible I really don't believe it's
possible to actually maintain a real
sense of what your constituency is
interested in without actually being
there and in today's world we can hold
multiple secure conferences from various
theatres of war on an airplane I think
we can rename post offices from home
just thought okay that's great and I'm
against all that and here's why I'm not
I'm thinking whether I really am against
it all but I guess a lot of it I'll tell
you why here's the argument in the
representative system I mean you know
you you ought to if you you know you
ought to take our online constitution
course ten times I teach it ten times
you can take it ten times because it's
really great and here's the intricacy of
the system the problem is that human
nature has these two features it is a
little lower than the Angels and it is a
little lower than the Angels and that's
really good and really bad and that
means that we've got our rights and we
do these glories you know I I'm
interested because I'm in the kid
business I say we have children also I
educate to young motherhood is a
profound thing to me I have a nice wife
and I had a great mother and I marvel at
all the mothers I know because remember
what
do it's harder for them to raise their
young than any other kind of creature
takes longer men - and yet they have
discretion over if they don't have to do
it
charity is how every human being grows
up so we're marvelous creatures right
but then we'll pick each other's pockets
so their idea was simple the first great
step is we're going to have this big
private society and it's gonna control
this very powerful but not necessarily
very big government and so power is
outside and government is inside now
step1 step2 representative that means
that that the government all works for
us but on the other hand we can't do
anything except through it and so both
the sovereign us and the government we
elect are restrained by that arrangement
third we have a big debate and we choose
people carefully and the eye idea is if
the government's organised right will
tend to get ones that are above the
common run and then they well you know
it's funny now it's too quick to laugh
over there and and and and you know for
a lot of the times we have got that and
you know those guys right there there's
just nothing common about those guys in
that picture and so then they have to
assemble and they have to think it
through and argue it through and this
and by the way the government is not
gonna do so many things that it won't be
time to argue there won't be too many
for them to argue through and so this
whole notion of representation of going
to a common place that's somewhere near
the center of that set of arrangements
in the way it was set up and if all you
are is just a guy living in the
community you know and you know getting
together then then the founders put an
enormous emphasis on deliberation and
both the people have to deliberate a
long time between elections and that
will encourage them to talk
and think and think before they act but
then you're supposed to have the
government operate in such a way so they
do gather on that floor and they argue
together and then they don't need to be
here sedan long and then they should go
home and the government should shut up
for a few months and then let the states
do the great majority of things they've
always done and that doesn't mean that
things here are not terribly important
they are decisively important to the
life and well-being of the nation it
just means you're not supposed to be
running all the details from here so I
imagine a government that's more like
the one designed in that painting and
not just a big national town hall so
that's what I think okay our final
question comes from Joanie viewing in
Marietta Georgia and she asks what
emerging trends you see that offer hope
that our American society could be
returning to our founding principles in
the near future well that's if you heard
that what signs do I see well I I live
in a very weird world because the signs
of return are everywhere apparent to me
everything we do at Hillsdale College is
attracting attention right we run this
to all you prospective students out
there all you grandmas and grandpas and
moms and dads and neighbors if you know
somebody who's really super smart and a
complete gut glutton for punishment age
seventeen send them to our miserable
College
where it is cold and the little town is
boring as heck and it's very hard we've
had five people get a four point in the
last 15 years you know one of the
smartest young lawyers in the country
sitting he's sitting in this room he's a
student of mine he's gonna be famous
he's graduated from the top yet Law
School in the country
need that smart he didn't graduate with
a four-point at Hillsdale College of
course right so if you want to go
through that misery and he'll please
come to our College we will accommodate
you and I will tell you we can't beat
them off of the stick so you know the
principles of justice and good are
highly desired the first sentence of
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics every
methodical undertaking every action
every art seems to aim at some good
therefore it has been beautifully said
that the good is that for which all
things aim seems still to be true to me
today
thank you very much dr. Arnn that
concludes our online Town Hall I went to
close by thanking my Kirby Center
colleagues the the wonderful staff who
made this event possible craig crime
bill ana Dunham Steven Ford Alice Arn
and our terrific intern our interns as
well we thank you very much for for
joining us and look forward to seeing
you in future webcast events thank you